[Applause]
now you know i love a good animal story
i've basically got a med degree in
pedigrees
it's time for dr drew little
all right we know you can't judge a book
by its cover and now it turns out you
can't judge a primate by its cute little
face either
the new york times reports that slow
lorises
these cute little guys you love to
tickle for enjoyment
are venomous they carry toxic venom
guess what
where in their upper arms i always
wondered what this was for
i get it now venom they raise up their
arms
and then lick lick lick and then the
poison
pools and then they bite bite bite
and their flesh rots from the saliva
scientists say that they mostly bite
each other and males are more likely to
bite than females
huh well hello that feels like a gender
war if i've ever heard one
look at that guy big eyes clear heart
full of poison
speaking of mammals exhibiting strange
behavior
a human man has been spotted flying a
jet pack near lax which is los angeles
international airport
for the second time people reports
that earlier this week china airlines
spotted the jetpack man at
6 000 feet and in september he was
flying within 30 yards of an american
airlines jet
now listen jet packs can't go that high
so are these ufos what is happening
2020 i'm telling you this is the year
aliens could come down and we'd be like
get in line okay get in line for the
craziness
listen people are nervous about getting
on a plane during a pandemic so maybe it
isn't such a bad idea to fly
jet pack airways you want to hang out
again
if you do i guess they say subscribe
but uh let's do this